okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about perimeter and area two important
concepts that you want to know for the
act so let's review some formulas that
you want to memorize and be familiar
with so for the circle the circumference
which is really like the perimeter of a
circle the circumference is pi times
diameter and remember pi is 3.14
or you could say the circumference
equals 2 pi r because twice the radius
is the same as the diameter
and then if you want to find the area of
a circle the area is just going to be pi
times the radius squared
now for a triangle the area is one half
base times height so the base is the
bottom the height is how tall the
triangle is that perpendicular distance
there
for a rectangle the area equals base
times height and then for a
parallelogram okay where the opposite
sides are parallel it's the base times
the height but you want to be careful
that you don't use
this length here you want the
perpendicular distance right there so
let's look at a couple examples that
you could potentially see on the ect
here it says find the area of the shaded
region okay so basically they're giving
us two circles okay that are inside this
rectangle so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can solve this one on
your own and we'll go through it
together
okay so the first thing you want to
notice here is that they're giving us
this one dimension it doesn't seem like
a lot to go on does it but basically you
know if this is four that means that the
diameter of this circle is four which
means the diameter of the circle this
direction would also be four that's four
so that really tells us that this entire
length here is 8. now what you want to
do in a problem like this is you want to
find the total area and then subtract
off the parts that you don't want that
will leave the left over okay this is a
common problem so basically we have 4
times 8 which is 32
minus we have to take the area of these
two circles away so the area of a circle
is pi r squared we've got two of those
so it's going to be 2 times pi and you
can see that the radius is half the
diameter that's just going to be 2 so pi
times 2 squared
2 squared is 4
times pi times 2 is 8 pi
so the exact answer will be 32 minus 8
pi
okay another example
that comes up quite a bit i've seen this
on a number of practice tests is where
they ask you to find the perimeter but
it's a complicated shape like this now
we know that the perimeter you just have
to add up you know all the sides so the
distance all the way around the object
but this can be a little bit time
consuming i'll show you a shortcut but
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can do this one on your own
so this distance is eight two this
height is two this length is three
here they're not giving us this uh
height but they're giving us this length
is two this height is two we don't know
this length and they're giving us this
height is two so go ahead and see if we
can solve that
and so this is how we would do it now so
basically a shortcut is what you can do
is you can think of this as a rectangle
okay
like so now what do i mean by this what
i mean is that pretend like these little
segments are actually detached like
they're not actually connected at the
vertices at the corners here so what
that allows us to do is it allows us to
push this segment here to the right push
this segment here to the right push this
segment here to the right so you're with
me we're just moving them to the right
and then with all these horizontal
lengths we can move those up
okay like so
and you can see it's forming a rectangle
now we know the perimeter of a rectangle
is just going to be eight
and eight right
and then we just have to add the two
widths now to find out these widths
let's see we have to add two
plus three is five
plus two is seven
and then this dimension here they
actually didn't give us that's my
mistake let's just say that this is
three so that would be ten so this whole
dimension here is ten
this whole dimension here is ten so if
we add up all the sides what do we have
here we've got uh eight plus eight is 16
10 plus 10 is 20 so we're looking at a
perimeter of 36
units
so that's the shortcut is just to think
about these segments as being detached
move them to the
right or move them up and then you can
see it pushes out into a rectangle and
it makes a lot easier to calculate the
perimeter so definitely perimeter and
area is something you want to know for
the act go ahead and review these
formulas make sure that you memorize
them and are familiar with those